nintendo Sony and Microsoft sell
consoles all over the world but when it
comes to the United States who sells the
most July marked the first month since
last October where the xbox one outsold
the ps4 this is a bit surprising
considering Microsoft had just announced
the xbox one s in project Scorpio at e3
the month before even more surprising
the 3ds outsold both of the major
consoles so how did Nintendo pull it off
at first credits monster hunter
generations which was the highest
selling game for any one platform in
July and you might have heard of a
little game called Pokemon go the mobile
games sparked interest in other Pokemon
titles which led to plenty of sales for
Omega Ruby alpha sapphire X&Y versions
the 2ds price drop this spring also
pushed some numbers bringing to TS sales
to over two million as for what's next
for the 3ds the heavy hitter on the
horizon is Pokemon Sun and Moon on
November eighteenth meanwhile Metroid
Prime Federation force is live right now
so you can check out our review and
progress at gamespot to keep up with all
the news from Nintendo in the big three
you're already in the right place